hey everyone I'm Rob and welcome to my
tutorial on how to make an origami
flapping bird in this tutorial I will
teach you how to make the bird using a
regular sheet of printer paper making
the bird is very similar to making the
origami crane but there are fewer folds
involved with making the bird give you
links to my other origami tutorials
please scroll down to the right and view
series playlist or you can visit my
channel by clicking on my name down to
the right as well once on my channel
simply click on the origami crane in my
channel banner to view all of my other
origami tutorials in order to make the
bird and also the crane we need to first
learn how to make bird base if you know
how to make the bird base I'll put a
small subtitle down here letting you
know where you could fast forward to in
the tutorial if you don't know how to
make the bird base that's what we're
going to learn how to do now to convert
your printer paper into a square take
one corner and fold it down to the
opposite side making sure that this edge
is aligned with the side edge make a
crease and then you could remove the
excess paper when you do so you'll have
a piece of paper that looks like this
and when you open it you'll notice you
now have a diagonal fold now we're going
to take the top of the paper and fold it
down in half so that it meets the bottom
end of the paper make a crease and then
when you open it you'll see you now have
a horizontal fold now we're going to
fold the paper in half going this way
take the top half again and fold it down
to the bottom half make another crease
so now when you open up the paper you'll
notice you now have a cross in the paper
and also a diagonal fold we want to take
the paper and fold it in half on the
diagonal fold make sure it's nice and
flat then we lift up the first layer of
paper and we're going to tuck this
corner in down towards the bottom in the
middle of the paper so tuck the corner
in and then we make really good creases
on those new folds which we just created
so now we want to take the left side of
the paper and tuck this corner and as
well so tuck it in and then we want to
flatten the entire structure out also so
make good creases all throughout the
paper now you should have a diamond
structure that looks just like this if
you made really good creases when you
were tucking in the corners then you
should notice a faint line that runs
vertically down the center of the
diamond if you don't notice the line
then you could take the entire diamond
and fold it in half and then make a
crease down the edge then you should
notice that you have a vertical line
what we're going to be doing in this
step is folding each of these four flaps
inwards towards the center of that line
so that this edge on the bottom aligns
with that vertical line so you want to
fold each of the flaps inwards just like
that and then make a crease so you
should have something that looks like
that and you want to do the same with
the remaining three flaps fold it
inwards and make a crease flip it over
and do the same in order to complete the
bird base we must now perform what is
known as the petal fold which is the
trickiest fold of making the bird base
I'm going to show you some ways now that
we can make the folding a little bit
easier one of the things you could do is
to take the tip of this kite and we're
going to fold it straight down so that
it folds along this edge here made by
these two flaps so you want to fold it
straight down along that edge and then
you make a crease unfold it flip the
model over and do the exact same thing
on this side
okay so now another thing you could do
is as you'll notice these flaps are
folded this way if we take each of these
flaps and fold them backwards on that
fold flip the model over do the same
thing on this side so fold it backwards
unfold it and just fold it backwards on
that line on that crease which we made
that will also make the petal fold a
little bit easier so now we could lay
the model flat on the table we're going
to lift up this first layer of paper and
you want to just kind of tug on it as
you'll see it might not want to fold
that way just kind of take your thumb
and push on those creases which were
made so tug upwards and you'll see these
edges will now go towards the center
take both of your hands and just push
gently on it and make good creases along
the outside of the petal fold so you
should have something that looks like
this flip the model over and do the
exact same thing lift up the first layer
of paper push outwards tug up on it and
then you want to just make the model
nice and flat by making really good
creases on the outside now that you've
completed the bird base just make sure
you're holding it so that these two
bottom halves are the ones that are
separate and the top should be solid
we're going to go on to make the head
and tail and also fold the wings down to
complete the bird turn the model on the
side and open up these two side flaps
we're then going to fold the point here
upwards all the way and then we're going
to close the two flaps on it pull the
point outwards and then we just want to
make sure that this is folded in half
nicely so just crease it along the edge
there so now you want to pull this point
outwards until this edge is aligned with
this edge here just pull it out to right
about there make a crease along the
bottom
and you should have something that looks
like this do the same with the left side
open up these two flaps fold the point
upwards close the flaps pull this out
make sure it's creased in half and then
you want to pull it out - right about
there make a crease along the bottom
okay so now all we have to do is to make
the head and to fold down the wings I'm
going to make the right side the head
and the left side is going to be the
tail so to make the head just open up
this point here in the middle push down
on the top of it and then just pinch the
top to make a crease then we're going to
be folding the wings towards the head
the tip of it is going to be more
towards the head I've made a line here
to show you exactly where there needs to
be folded from here down to here so you
want to fold it along that line and then
you want to make a crease flip the model
over and now you can kind of line this
wing up with the other wing so fold it
down and then make another crease then
you can just lift the wings up a little
bit and to make a stand we need to just
take these points and fold them outwards
and then to make it flap all you need to
do is to hold it here by the neck and
then just pull on the tail if it if it
seems like it's going to rip all you
need to do is just kind of pull outwards
on this a little bit like I showed you
just fold outwards and then it shouldn't
it should be fine just hold on it and
there you go you have your flapping bird
so I hope you guys enjoy the tutorial
and be sure to comment rate and
subscribe I'm thinking of making an
origami ring tutorial out of a dollar
bill so let me know what you think of
that and thanks for watching